c'est une journée internationale des
droits de l'enfant un peu particulière
ce vendredi 20 novembre à guyancourt
avec la crise sanitaire impossible
d'organiser le grand rassemblement avec
500 enfants de cm2 et de 6e comme c'est
la coutume mais la ville a tout de même
souhaité organiser quelque chose et
c'est donc adapté donc on a décidé de
mettre en place une formule un peu
différente avec vous savez on a un
conseil municipal on en vient de fêter
les 30 ans et donc on aura des
ambassadeurs de ce conseil municipal des
enfants qui auront dans les écoles cm1
cm2 voir des classes directement et
expliquer ce que c'est que la convention
entre internationale des droits de
l'enfant la convention internationale
des droits de l'enfant a été créé en
les responsables politiques se sont
engagés à construire un monde digne des
enfants
c'est dans ce but que guyancourt
organise chaque année des animations
l'objectif c'est d'expliquer un petit
peu aux enfants les sensibilités
désensibiliser pendant cette convention
leur expliquer tous les droits qui sont
intégrés dans cette convention est tous
bien sûr quand on a des droits et des
devoirs tous les deux voir associer
cette convention et puis aussi un moyen
de les ouvrir sur le monde d'ouvrir à
l'extérieur et puis de commencer a alors
donné une culture du citoyen les
premiers gestes de citoyens depuis 2006
la commune est aussi ville amie des
enfants
ce titre créé en 2002 c'est l'unicef qui
l'attribuent nous apporte des formations
nous apporte des kits condé propre des
enfants donc c'est un partenariat entre
la ville de lyon court et puis et
l'unicef dont dans le cadre de ce pacte
dans le cadre de ce partenariat
donc le dossier qui va être renouvelé en
décembre on va les articulés autour de
plusieurs thèmes dont il ya la lutte
contre l'exclusion
le bien-être de l'enfant la qualité de
l'éducation en est capable de proposer
sur le court et bien sûr tous les
partenariats qu'on construira avec
l'unicef
après versailles et saint germain en
laye guyancourt est l'une des premières
communes à avoir fait partie de ce
réseau dans les yvelines
au total 250 communes de france
bénéficient de ce titre de ville amie
des enfants dont 14 sont yvelinoise